now you said you you act like it's very
carefree you and your husband no kids
but you do have a dog to take care of
that's true Saturn by the minute what's
your dog's name
her name is buns buns okay his buns
distracting you at all during this time
of she is obviously an angel dog she's
perfect in every way she is really
acclimated to this new life where she
doesn't go out as much and walk as much
and uh since I have no acting thing to
promote pretty much the most exciting
thing that happened this week was I I
put a rice cake on on buns his head and
I realized she looked exactly like the
character Yankee from the show on
Orthodox
I saw this here in here it buns with the
rice cake on his head and there had her
head sorry here's the side by side with
Yankee and this is impressive it's
really tight the two images together
that is quite honestly the most exciting
thing that has happened in this house
you know what I've loved that I love
that over the years I've interviewed you
for all these really big movies shows
and you've always got this big thing to
promote and I love that this is a
special time we're in where it's okay
Lizzy let's get to the promotion you're
like all right my dog buns
looks like Yankee from his show
unorthodox
with the rice cake which is shocking
because only when you put the rice cake
looks like Gigi Hadid yeah I know but I
just I just just it's a very special
time we're never gonna get to do that
again where I where I end a segment by
by saying make sure you check out
Lizzy's dog buns with a rice cake on her
head as yong-ki from unorthodox
what is their point even making movies
when you have content like this don't
you think I this is gonna stick in my
mind I mean ticket might have to stick
in my mind for at least a long way